welcome back to PE sens I'm joined by
today's P Jeremy Corbin's former advisor
James Schneider talk to the contributor
Esther krku and the daily M's associate
editor Kevin Maguire okay let's talk
about this extraordinary interview with
the president of Israel um what did you
make of it Kevin look he's hurting he's
Head of State uh in Israeli politics
he's from the labor party he's a Social
Democrat he believes in a a peace
process but the the whole country is
traumatized and you can see him striking
out I think I think where I would take
issue with him is on Palestinian
casualties in Gaza and also humanitarian
Aid which has been absolutely squeezed
by by Israel and I think you know the
whole conflict it depends who you talk
to who you get an answer from and you
know polarized one of the most powerful
pieces I read about this was by Jonathan
Friedland and the guardian who said you
know if you go back over the history of
this whole conflict you can find just
cause for both sides and the tragedy is
that they've not been able to achieve
peace and you got to say that what
happened on October the 7th has put back
any chance of Peace in the short to
medium term I would have thought back to
you know the Dark Ages but what is your
response to what the president said well
there was no Prospect for peace
unfortunately on the 6th of October let
alone on the 7th of October and that is
because Israel has not been involved in
a peace process with the Palestinians I
note that the only time uh Isaac H said
the word Palestine was to refer to that
being where his father was from um when
he was fighting he does believe in a two
State solution and I would say there's
far more chance of Peace actually with
somebody like him if he was to become
Prime Minister which he might uh than BB
nety who I think is a dead man walking
in terms of his political future of
course but let me make the point that
netanyahu's policy has been to not go
for a two-state solution to make it
impossible through ethnic cleansing in
the w West Bank and Trea uh and actually
supporting Hamas over the Palestinian uh
Authority he's on record time and time
again talking about that and why it was
important to fund them uh and treating
the Palestinians as purely a security
issue not a people who have rights and
who need to be negotiated with and of
course that has you know we've seen the
result of that policy in in in murder
and in Bloodshed uh and the president
didn't engage with any of that at all in
fact you know this is the head of state
of a state which is engaging in clear
war crimes as we speak and rather than
engaging with any of those issues he
just said what do you think the war
crimes are so there's Collective
punishment that is taking place of yes I
know I know let please let me let let me
say so there's Collective punishment of
of a number of sorts there denial of
things for example water electricity
food fuel uh telecoms internet there's
the war crime of collective punishment
over half the whole homes in Gaza have
been raised to Rubble uh if you have
4,000 children who have died there by
definition innocent the idea that uh
that that this is in any way surgical
show me then what is
disproportionate let ask and and let me
ask you a what was your reaction to What
happened on October the
7th uh to to what what aspect of it your
reaction to What well he I mean of
course hearing as the as president hog
laid out what happened in the kts what
happened at the music festival is
absolutely horrific those are clearly
atrocities now now now the response
those ATR let me yeah so what do you do
about the people that did it so uh I
think what a States person like leader
of Israel and Israel unfortunately
doesn't have any states person like
leaders would do it would be immediately
reinforce the Negev uh taking troops out
of the West Bank where they're currently
overseeing the ethnic cleansing of
Palestinians and then and I know this
sounds very difficult and very painful
with all of the pain we just heard from
uh the father of someone who who died in
the music festival it's then Su for
piece and actually Su piece which means
you don't try meang on this is the
problem you see this is where I think
there's a lot of with respect naivity
about this situation how do you forge
peace with Hamas who are the controlling
Authority in Gaza given that they are
bloodthirsty by their own proud
admission they boasted about what they
did to the world and they said last week
through their spokesman we're going to
try and do it again and again and again
how do you forge peace with people who
committed Terror on that level I think
you can turn it around and say exactly
the way I'm not condoning any of I know
but I'm asking about ham I'm asking you
about ham and what not about Israel no
no no I I know and I'm saying what's the
answer let me say any peace comes with
people that don't like each other that
have said horrific things to each other
that have done horrific things to each
other that is what leadership is
leadership a terror group do do you know
what the word you're looking for is
accountability what Hamas did on October
the 7th is quite clearly a war crime and
if this was in a backward African
country we'll be saying put them in
front of the international criminal
court and try them that's what should be
done to Hamas the president said that
Israel is following humanitarian law
okay prove it stand in front of a court
and and and attest to your record of
what you doing in Gaza this is the
problem there's been a lack of political
will because have a problem James and
there's no accountability right but I
have a problem with with the equivalence
of someone a group a terror organization
outlawed in this country as a terror
group of trying to give them any kind of
I don't know um equivalence to a nor
like like for example the norn iseland
peace process right I've heard people
trying to compare it there was no
equivalence here what Hamas did is
clearly a war crime there's nobody
justifying but also there's no desire
hang on hang on that's all there's no
desire by Hamas for peace their stated
Charter mission is the Eric ation of
Israel and they will kill any Jewish
people to achieve that stated goal it's
not like Northern Ireland where there
was a genuine political battle raging
albe it with with terrorism as part of
that but they had a will in the end for
peace which they achieved Hamas are
never going to want peace so Hamas
cannot stay there part of any peace
James answer in his own way but I'm old
enough and you'll be old enough to
remember when the PLO fata yasa Arafat
didn't accept the state of is
and was condemned as a terrorist
organization and then through the Oslo
Accords in 1993 and the agreement accept
accept can't do peace with Hamas are we
agreed on but why having think Hamas why
not because they're a bloodthirsty
terror group there's 40,000 of them and
they want to eradicate Israel they're
not after some cozy political peace they
don't want peace nobody is right now
nobody is after a cozy political
agreement in the government of Israel
which has has a many annexationist far
right politicians speaking with
genocidal intent they don't want no no
they're not speaking with genocidal
intent
well one person the one person the one
person who talked about nuking has been
suspended right because they and they've
all they've all of course should be you
didn't quote Isaac herzog's own words
back to him where he said it's not just
Hamas it's an entire nation that is
responsible that's what he said Isaac
Herzog about this the man that you
interview well but this I think
the top of the Israeli state are not not
specific my point is those are the very
people you need to make peace the
Palestinians need to make peace with
Israel Israel have hog has been a chief
person to do this have repeatedly talked
about wanting a two-state solution not
Netanyahu I don't think he can stay as
leader I don't think his people want him
to stay as leader but I definitely don't
see any intent by Israel to
obliterate Palestine the the Gaza really
oh no I don't you don't you don't you
you so what part of their mission
statement is not to eradicate all
Palestinian what eradicate Israel what
part of the expansion of the settlement
I don't age with that right what part of
that is is not obliterating Palestine
what part of the destruction of Gaza now
is
not the illegal settlements which have
been growing and growing growing they
are completely wrong they are deeply
inflammatory and they are wrong and they
have to stop right but I I believe in
two-state solution where you have two
sets of people who can live side by side
with the exactly the same human rights
and the question is how do you get there
you cannot get there if you're on the
Israel side you cannot get there with a
terror group who stated mission is the
eradication of the whole of is I agree
we at least we can agree that on both
sides there's been a spectacular failure
of political leadership and because of
that there has been no actual will to
even try and negotiate a two-state
solution and to to well theyve come
quite close actually they hav't because
away from what now looks like very
that was over 20 years ago most Israelis
now can't even fathom what a two-state
solution would look like what even the
borders would look like if you want to
if you want to restore political will
you need to restore accountability and
Trust both parties need to attest to
their record before the international
criminal court like you would have any
African country do but when it comes to
the west and its allies we're not
willing to attest to our record all
right Kevin this question of
proportionality it was interesting
listening to the president because they
are a nation in trauma yeah and he more
than most because of what his father
went through in World War II you know
liberating the bellson concentration
camp and so on and the idea you're going
through this horror again in 2023 must
be particularly traumatic and horrifying
you have to AC accept that um and I if
your statement as a country as theirs is
is we need to get rid of aass and there
are 40,000 of them living in civilian
populations I don't know how else they
can do that without the way they're
doing it which involves horrifically
Mass civilian casualties too no well if
your aim is to kill every last one and
you don't really care about civilians
dying two Palestinians you just see them
as somehow collateral damage then look
as Kim D the former National Security
adviser at the UK government said you're
creating the next generation of Hamas
Fighters terrorists call them what you
like on the streets of of Gaza look it's
clearly a breach of international law on
The Siege you know withholding the food
the water the power the medical supplies
killing so many people that was 70%
women and children clearly
non-combatants it would take a longer a
longer military process and it would
also take needs AAL it needs a political
post who going to manage Gaza afterwards
look one of the things that said in the
interview was that there was no
unsurvivable humanitarian crisis before
October the 7th 90% of gazans didn't
have access to clean water right over
half of the population was at risk of
starving there was clear there's clearly
been a humanitarian crisis since since
2006 most most of those people respons
for her not even BN when herass came
into J's right to a point but I mean has
she expressed similar outrage over what
have in October the 7th no she hasn't
and my problem is about people who get
extremely exercised about the response
by Israel but said absolutely nothing
about what happened on October 7th and
there are lots of them by the way and I
would ask all these people marching
marching for the for in the prop
palestin marches all right fine but what
did you say about October the 7th
because if you didn't condemn that then
I'm not listening
to because I'm I'm I've been on the
marches I'll continue to go on the
marches and by the way you're entirely
wrong when you say they're sh shouting
Jihad that's just design SC they've been
seen and recorded Jad there was a hisb
but terer Splinter off from the from the
main thing there's a video of it it's
not very many people and there's a
couple I've seen many chances from the
river to the sea that means the
eradication Israel no it no it doesn't
it everybody knows it does no it doesn't
pce it means equal rights and dignity
for all yes it does it it means you know
that's not what it means people who try
and pretend it doesn't mean the
eradication of Israel they either
deluded ill informed or willfully
deliberately refusing I am none of those
three things I N I'm none of those three
things it does not mean what you are
telling people it means there are
Palestinians who are dispossessed and
denied between the river georan and the
Mediterranean Sea as they have been for
many decades to say from The River To
The Sea Palestine will be free is a call
for liberation for people who have been
dened that that is what that us
congresswoman said and and she's that
Palestinian congresswoman who is a
Palestinian origin congressman who
Rashida who is who is quite right about
it she's in my estimation she's
deliberately saying something knows but
to go back to your your point about the
protests and and what is being protested
the reason why the protests are focused
on uh British support and complicity in
Israeli war crimes and on on Saturday
today will be on his uh us support as
the March is going nowhere near the
sener whatsoever and it's going from
hide Park to the US Embassy which is in
baty well away from the Senate half is
because we can have a role in helping
end the crimes that have been committed
we have no association whatsoever to
okay but again what about the role you
want to play in the crimes Hamas have
committed you seem to want Hamas to stay
there some peace deal to be done with
the terrorist who committed this Terror
and again it comes down to I get your
passion for the Palestinians I share a
lot of the views that they've been
treated appallingly right but I'm sorry
if you don't feel as strongly about
getting rid of herass after what they
did why should we take it seriously okay
so the role that we we're sitting here
in London and our government provides
diplomatic cover and Military Support
for Israel to carry out its war crimes
right we have we can indirectly perhaps
and we should influence what's going on
with Hamas through our allies katar just
clear you think any response militarily
by Israel into Gaza against Hamas is a
war crime no that's not what I said do
you think that no I
think I don't I think war crimes are war
crimes I think things such are war
crimes in international La so you're
alleging War just be clear you're
alleging war crimes they've not
following the following the great
massive opinion inter L lot of opinions
it doesn't make it a fact interal
doesn't make it a fact and it should be
tested exactly doesn't make fact but
what military response by Israel would
you think is acceptable and not a war
crime against Hamas things that don't
breach war crimes like what attacks on
Military
insulations they would argue all their
targets they obviously made big mistakes
as you do in war but they would argue
that they hospitals we know that Hamas
conv we know that Hamas use all these 8
un Aid workers killed these are not com
know these are not military Target we
know that Hamas use hospitals and
schools and other buildings of that
nature to to plan their operations from
because they don't care about civilian
this is not a problem that can go away
with military intervention and that's
the point I've been making Hamas should
hang and you know where they should hang
at the hag they shouldn't be hanged with
the thousands of innocent women and
children that are being crucified at the
altar of getting rid of Hamas by the way
this is not going to get rid of it Hamas
provides the schools it provides the
hospitals provides the welfare
organizations it also also SP much of
the money that they've been given on
actually on waging Terror against the
people of Israel that is inarguable too
I know I agree with that but it is not a
simple terrorist organization that that
is actually I think it's become that
exactly that no it committ it wasn't to
start with they've proven October the
7th if they get the chance they'll kill
any Jew they can get their hands on
committed and you if you're in Israel
you cannot accept that it committed a
terrible atrocity it was an
it was bar it a war Terror ATT but it it
sounds TR but two wrongs don't make a
right when innocent Palestinians are we
didn't say this about Isis we said we
got to get rid of them no but here and
by the way a lot of civilians died in
the world the world and there are people
that are that was wrong too there are
people that are calling for the West to
be held accountable for that now Isis
Al-Qaeda they're the latest Incarnation
they have shown that October the 7th and
they got to be treated as they're all
different we leave it there thank you
all of you it was a good debate thank
you very
much